I've not blown up a balloon in years.
Scientists know the universe
is expanding like a balloon getting
bigger and bigger.
But what's causing this expansion
and will it continue forever?
This is the show that asks
scientists the big questions
in the time it takes to travel up
and down 45 floors.
Hey, Tara.
I hear that you're going to expand
my mind with some information about
the expanding universe.
Yes. Do you think my mind can take
it? I hope so. Can it expand as much
as the universe?
No.
OK, let's learn.
I'm a bit scared of lifts.
Let's set the lift right first.
You're
scared of lifts?
A little bit. Well, this is a great
place for you to be.
OK, well, let's go! So the universe
is expanding. What is that about?
When we looked at galaxies in the
early 20th century, we realised that
they were moving away from us.
And the further they were, they were
moving faster.
So the universe is expanding.
What is that expansion?
What's happening there?
Is more matter being created?
No, the space between matter
is expanding, but only on the
larger scale.
So if you imagine some dough with
raisins in put in the oven and
heated up, the dough expands.
And so all the raisins are moving
away from each other because the
space between them is expanding.
So the raisins are planets and the
dough is just empty space.
They're not planets they're groups
of galaxies.
Our solar system is joined together
because of gravity.
And is that gravity lessening?
No. So gravity actually holds
our solar system together and our
galaxy and our group of galaxies.
It's the space between them that is
expanding.
And we're halfway through.
Oh wow.
That was quick. Yeah, that was
really quick. OK, where were we?
So groups of galaxies are moving.
Why are they moving? What's causing
this?
We think it's a property of space
itself. The vacuum of space
has a kind of weird energy that we
call dark energy.
We think it makes up 70 percent of
the universe and it's what's causing
the universe to expand and actually
accelerate. So is that dark energy
filling those spaces or is it just
causing that push? It seems to be
part of the nature of space
itself.
It means that ultimately we're going
to have a really sad, lonely
death. As the groups of galaxies
get further apart, the universe
will kind of become cold and lonely
for each of them.
And so that's kind of our inevitable
end. We'll die a really sad death.
That's really terrifying
and not at all where I thought
this was going to go.
Right, but the good thing for humans
is that the Sun is halfway through
its life and in about another four
billion years, it will have expanded
to be a giant star and it will have
boiled the oceans and burnt up
everything on Earth. So we won't be
around for the sad, lonely death.
Well, you've given me much to think
about with a cold,
frozen universe
contrasted to a boiling
hot Earth that just kills
us all.
That's right. That will happen
first. Wonderful.
I don't think you know what good
news means.
So we know the universe is
expanding.
But the big thing is that it's also
accelerating.
And I will admit, I stole a little
bit of Tara's time outside of
the elevator because I really wanted
to know more about how we know
this, how we measure it.
And I found out about a little thing
called redshift.
So basically what this is, it's kind
of like measuring the Doppler effect
with sound, right?
So, you know, you hear an ambulance
coming towards you and it gets
higher pitch than lower and it goes
yewww.
The same thing happens with light.
So as things move further away from
us and we're looking at them, the
frequency gets lower and it shifts
towards red.
And because of this, we can also
see that it's moving faster
and faster. And that's really
exciting to take a look at.
Now, will the universe
keep expanding indefinitely?
Probably.
However, we will not be around to
see it. So, you know, does it
really matter? Yes, it does.
That is all from me and Elevator
Pitch. I'll see you next time.
Hey, thanks for watching.
If you want to see our Elevator
Pitch about what happened before the
Big Bang, then you can see that
here. And if you want to see more
videos like this, then don't forget
to hit, subscribe. See ya!